1500 militants ump beaucoup de
parlementaires d'élus locaux rassemblés
ce mardi soir à poissy pour attendre
leur favori à la présidence de l'ump
l'ancien premier ministre françois
fillon une ambiance emmenés par un
tandem david douillet député de la
circonscription et valérie pécresse
c'est un véritable homme d'état c'est
quelqu'un qui a su diriger la france
d'une même m côté nicolas sarkozy
pendant cinq ans et j'ai eu cette chance
d'être à ses côtés pendant un an tant
que ministre et donc la vraie manger
j'ai connu un vrai chef
voilà un chef qui sait prendre du recul
un chef qui sait analyser qui sait
écouter surtout regagné dans les yeux
dès 2014 avec françois fillon c'est
possible parce que c'est le seul qui
peut à la fois être suffisamment ferme
pour nous ramener les électeurs qui sont
partis au front national et en même
temps suffisamment républicain ouvert
sera pour nous ramener les électeurs
centristes qui sont partis voter
hollande
rassembler le maître mot de cette soirée
rassemblés au sens large
françois fillon ne s'en cache pas il en
profite même pour égratigner son
adversaire mais jean françois copé
cette stratégie du rassemblement me
distingue jean françois est bon en
réalité la question de la ligne
politique que vous allez choisir et
c'est normal que dans une élection vous
ayez à choisir une ligne politique
certains pensent que l'on reverra la
france en prenant tous les virages à
droite
moi j'ai la conviction qu'on la gagnera
par la droite par le chant et même par
la gauche
une fin de campagne ici dans les
yvelines ce n'est pas un hasard pour
françois fillon car il l'a rappelé
pendant son discours
s'il devient président de l'ump c'est
valérie pécresse qui deviendra l
secrétaire général
d'abord elle a participé d'une façon
extraordinaire à la campagne mais
surtout elle al étoffe
quand secrétaire général de l'ump dont
j'ai besoin pour rénover notre parti et
pour pouvoir si les militants me font
confiance me consacrer totalement à
porter le message de l'ump est allé
au-devant des français dernière ligne
droite donc avant l'élection jean
françois copé lui tiendra son dernier
meeting ce samedi également dans le
département à saint germain en laye il
est de son côté soutenue par henri
guaino l'ancienne plume de nicolas
sarkozy ou jean frédéric poisson lé
député de la 10e circonscription j'ai
été membre du groupe ump dans la
mandature précédente je les ai vus
diriger le groupe politique notre groupe
politique à l'assemblée nationale je l'
ai vu diriger comme secrétaire national
de l'ump que je suis encore notre
famille politique et il a montré dans
ces deux circonstances
des qualités qui sont essentiels à mon
avis pour diriger ce genre
d'organisation ce travail là je pense
jean-françois copé a envie de le faire
il envie de le faire d'une manière qui
me convient donc pour ces trois raisons
une fiction
les militants ump sont donc amenés à se
prononcer ce dimanche dans les yvelines
12000 sont invités à se rendre aux urnes